היי, שמי סברינה וואלאס, והורי היו שניהם חלק מחיל החלל בשנת 1969.
פשוט במקרה יש קריסטל יפה בצורה דומה.
עכשיו, הרבה אנשים אוהבים להגיד דברים שאנחנו לא בהכרח אוהבים לעלות ולעזור לאנשים להבין דברים שקשה להבין כי, אתם יודעים, כולם עסוקים כרגע בהכנות ללוחמה של מזל"טים, לוחמת מזל"ט אלקטרומגנטית.
עשינו את זה בעיראק ואז ממש לפני ואתה יודע, המדינה הולכת למלחמה בדרך זו או אחרת.
בין אם זה יהיה או לא, אתם יודעים, האנשים שלנו או משהו אחר, יש לנו ליקוי למידה רציני בארצות הברית.
בין אם הוא תוכנן ועוצב ובין אם לאו.
אני הולך לתת לאנשים אחרים לדבר על זה.
מה שאני הולך לעשות היום זה להראות לכם בדיוק מה אתם צריכים להסביר לילדים שלכם כדי שנוכל להימנע ממהפכת סגנון הפה, אני די בטוח שזה מה שהם באמת מתרגזים.
ואנחנו הולכים לעשות את זה עם החינוך.
אז אני מתחיל.
אנחנו לא.
שמי סברינה וואלאס.
אני ילד של אוסטין.
ובני משפחתי מעורבים בפרויקטים שחורים, פרויקטים של גישה מיוחדת seps.
אז אני חבר BAIER וסבא שלי הוא ברנרד היינריך כאן, והשם הזה הוא מר..
הוא התחתן עם הלן הרדינג, והלן הרדינג קשורה ישירות לפיוס לוי.
אבי היה סטיבן גרלנד דייויס.
אמא שלי היא לין ג'ין שיר.
שניהם סופר מרכזי סודי.
בשנת 1969, בעבודה על פרויקט שתיקה, אני ילד שונה עקב ניסויים של קרן מנינגר להגדלת בני אדם.
עכשיו, כל מה שזה אומר הוא שיש לי צלקות שלרוב האנשים אין לארכיטקטורה של ג'ון פון נוימן.
זה לא ממשק בין מוח למכונה.
זה מסת גוף.
זה בלתי אפשרי.
וזה נשמע מה שוב?
אני מחזיק מעמד שם.
אז הנה רשימת החתונות של ההורים שלי.
בסדר.
הנה רישומי הטיסה מאדג'ווד ארסנל עבור דוד רבא שלי.
65/70 כימיקל צבאי, פורט דיטריך.
-לאן?
-טקסס.
ניו יורק, צפון קוריאה.
רק אחד לא מספיק טוב.
אלינור הול זה עדיין בשביל השלושה.
אני כנראה כאן הייתי מעורב בפרויקטים של איש עש ובבניית כלי רכב לגברים בשחור.
עכשיו, הממשק לצלקות ג'ון פון נוימן נמצא ממש מתחת לכאן.
אני רואה שם אחד.
וכמובן, אני מבוגר עכשיו, אבל זה הלב שלך.
אוקיי, אז זה ממשק גוף מכונה עם מסד נתונים תת קרקעי שנקרא הבא יותר, שהוא IBM.
אז בשיעור הגרמני שלי בתיכון, אייתתי את זה לא נכון.
ניק נפל בצד ימין שם.
בסדר.
למה זה משנה?
כי אם אנשים אומרים דברים כאלה, מוטב שהם יוכלו להראות לך ראיות, הוכחות קיימא, אחרת לא הייתי מקשיב להם.
אוקיי, אז הנה קצת יותר תיעוד, ואז אנחנו הולכים קדימה ולהתחיל עם הדיון האינטלקטואלי.
בסדר.
אז הנה המשפחה שלי וגרלנד כאן.
סבא שלי, גרלנד דייויס, חייל מארינס ממלחמת העולם השנייה.
פורט מיד, NSA.
מממ הממ.
ראשית, הוא התחתן עם אליזבת קראפט.
אבל אני חושב שמשהו עם ה-DNA לא לקח.
אז הוא התחתן עם אמא שלי.
דודה.
בסדר.
אז עבדת בחברה שהייתה ההורים שלי והדוד הגדול שלי.
אה, מצטער.
שכחתי דבר אחד.
הדוד שלי, הדוד שלי הוא המקום שבו אני גר.
אז הוא.
הוא תמיד היה אחד האנשים האהובים עלי.
זה אדם אדיב מאוד.
הו, קדימה עם.
הפעם היה לי הכל יושב ממש על הסיפור.
בסדר.
הו.
כל כך דרומי.
אז יש לי סיפור אחר לגמרי מההורים שלי.
אף פעם לא אמרו לי כלום.
-כלום.
אז התבגרתי ורציתי את זה.
והם אמרו לי ששום דבר לא קיים חוץ ממה שאתה יכול לראות.
ורציתי לדעת מה זה כל החומר האלקטרומגנטי הזה?
גדלתי בשנות השמונים, בשנות התשעים.
נולדתי ב-1979, ואם דיברתם על ההילה, כולם דחפו אתכם לפינה ודרשו מכם להצטרף לקבוצת הקוראים שלהם.
ואני תמיד ישבתי שם כאילו, אתה מבין שזה חלק בגוף.
ואני אוהב, לא, אתה טיפש.
אתה חייב שתהיה לך דת.
אף פעם לא הבנתי מה אני.
לא ידעתי למה אנשים מתנהגים כל כך טיפשים כמו למה שתשקר לגבי חלק בגוף?
ובכל זאת ההורים שלי היו סנאים סודיים.
זה ארבע רמות של אכיפת החוק מעל כל מה שאזרחים רואים.
והם האקס.
האליטה הסודית.
מה?
זה שירות אליטה חשאי.
וזה פחות או יותר הכל.
ברגע שאתה שם, זה אכיפת חוק סודית.
כרגע, אתה חייב לעלות רמה נוספת.
אוקיי, עכשיו אני צריך לעלות רמה נוספת.
הם רציניים.
כן, אני זוכה לעלות רמה נוספת.
נכון.
אז המשכתי והלכתי לעבוד בחברה מלואיוויל, קנטקי, שנקראת גישה מהירה.
וזה כאשר הם שלחו לי את המסמכים שלי לעבוד כדי שהם יראו שם.
הם פשוט תפסו את הזיעה הבוגרת הישנה שלהם.
זוהי חזרה לחלל עבורנו.
הקצה האחורי האמיתי של המדינה הזאת.
הייתי אחד משני טכנאים שחייגו את מדינת ויסקונסין מהחיוג לפס רחב.
אז אני מאוד ברור.
L-3 האריס או C 24, כל הדרכים השונות שאנו מטפלים בהן עם כל מיני סוגים של אינטליגנציה, תוכנית PRISM של הסוכנות לביטחון לאומי, כל זה כולל חבילות של גראם נתונים.
הנדסת רשת אינה זהה להתקנת מודם כבלים.
אני צריך לעבוד עם טכנאי המפעל ומהנדס המפעל.
אין אף אחד ששוכר מפעל בזה.
ולא היה אף אחד שכיר בתפקיד הזה שלי מלבד זה שעושה זאת.
כן, הייתי בן 19.
אז לתיירות בינלאומית כך שככל שאני ממשיך כאן ולאנשים באמת לא היה מה להגיד לי כי אני בדיוק איפה שאני אומר לכם שאני נמצא.
גוף מלא.
סליחה על הרגל המלוכלכת שלי.
בסדר, אז, אחות.
בוא נראה.
שאלתי שירותים טכניים, רשת קמפוס מקצועית של UW Whitewater, חבילות תוכנה שונות, כולל הרבה זהב ברשת מפות, HP וינטאג ', תצוגה פתוחה באינטראקציות קצרות עם נחירה.
פעולות המשמרת השנייה כוללות עיבוד מסדי נתונים באמצעות PeopleSoft, שמונה נתבי קידוד ומתגים מעודכנים, עבודה עם Visio ליצירת מפת סיבים של הכשרה יזומה בקמפוס למה שפשוט, כמובן, זה הרבה מצב שלם כמו נתח אחד קטן.
כשהלכתי למרכז תפעול הרשת, לואיוויל, או שרציתי לבנות לי אחד מאותם יועצי רשת ב- Omni Resources בגרין ביי.
בעיות בעימותים במערכת ההפעלה, צרות סטודנטים, סכסוכי מערב הלם.
החברה הקניינית פיתחה תוכנה, בסיוע בסיוע תוכנית חומת אש קבועה של סיסקו למחלקת התיקונים ויילס, ויסקונסין מותקנת ומיושמת מחלקת תחזוקת מתקני תוכנית מעקב פנימית של בית הספר לבנים איתן אלן לפתח מסדי נתונים וגישה ולספק כיוון לפתרון בעיות רשת ושולחן עבודה בתוך המחלקות ועבודה גדולה.
באוקטובר 1999 עד 22 במאי, צ'רטר תקשורת שמרה על שדרוג ולימדה ופתרון בעיות ברשת האינטרנט המורכבת מסיסקו שלוש קונג Comm 21 ו- Bay Networks היו חמישה מתלים מותקנים והיו להם בעונה.
הנהלת קולין כבלים האחראית לדוח שבועי וחודשי על בדיקת רוחב פס ושימוש במעגל החזירה מודמים בכבלים, בעיות אחריות או פריסה מחדש, תחום אחריות כיסוי קל ליותר מ -12,000 לקוחות המותקנים ומתחזקים שרתי Cisco AC 5300 לשבע בריכות נפרדות מנוטרות ברוחב הפס בתצורת Cisco 7200 נתבים עם שדרוגים עבור 9000 לקוחות ולנהל יחסים בין מפעיל כבלים לטכנאים בפליינפילד, אילינוי, תוך הכשרת צוות חדש בתפקידים הטכניים והמנהליים בינואר 2001.
בדוק את רשימת התוכנה וזה משהו שהושבת לצמיתות בשנת 2004 בגלל שהיא מדוכאת על ידי הממשלה שלה.
כדי לסגור את הדלת על זה נאמר האם אתה עדיין טלפתי הולך לפי פרויקטים?
אתה יודע, אולי אתה לא, אבל עכשיו זה הולך להיות כיף.
אז לאן אנחנו הולכים מכאן הוא שאנחנו הולכים לטייל לתוך המציאות של היום בשנת 2022.
ודבר ראשון, יהיה לנו שיעור קטן מהעבר.
בעבודה שלי כשעבדתי ב- UW ווייטווטר.
יש לה מגנט ענק מתחתיה בלוויין קבוע במסלול כדור הארץ נמוך מעליה.
ובמהלך שנות השבעים, ל- UW Whitewater הייתה חבורה של תוכנות שהיו קיימות עבור כל אותם ניק פרלונג המחתרתיים, מסדי נתונים של יבמ וכדומה.
הם מתחת לאדמה.
אז זה לא אולי זה בטוח.
זה קשור לקירור יותר מכל דבר אחר.
אז שוב, כילד, אני גדל ומצייר דברים כמו זה שהם בדקו ממשק מוח מוחי לטלפתיה סינתטית.
ואנשים כבר מזמן שיקרו להם לגבי חלק הגוף האלקטרומגנטי הזה.
ועכשיו אנחנו במשבר במדינה שלנו.
זה משנת 1993, וככה מתנהל פריסות ה- Bluetooth של זיגבי.
ככה הם נראים.
וזה בדיוק גם איך הם מעבדים בתקשורת.
ואני הולך להראות לי את כל זה.
אבל אני רוצה לציין שהם בדקו ילדים.
כן, זה מה שהממשלה שלנו עושה.
ההורים שלי, ההורים שלי, הם פשוט מסגירים אותך.
זה התפקיד שלהם.
זה פריסה סודית עבור סינכרוני.
לא.
מצטער, אנשים.
לא, אני חוזר לזה בדיוק באותו אופן.
אז המסע הזה בשבילי באמת התחיל שם בהיותי ילד סורק בעיות פעולה, שזה בעצם רק שיש לי שליטה על כל הפיזיולוגיה שלי במקום להקשיב לאנשים סביבי מספרים לי סיפור שאומר לי איך להבריח אותי מלהיות מסוגל פשוט להרגיש את הגוף שלי.
וגדלתי משנת 1979, תמיד מצאתי את זה מוזר, יוצא דופן, אבל לא ידעתי.
לא הבנתי שהלב של המעקב הוא הביופילמים האנושיים.
וברגע שעשיתי את זה, זה לא היה בסדר.
והמשפחה שלי גרמה לי לעזוב כמעט עשור כי אסור היה לי להגיד שום דבר מעולם ממוט.
כריס זה שנות הסתיו.
בשנת 2019 רצתי עם אחת מאנגליה שנקראה אמבולנס, ובטלפון הבחור באמבולנס אמר, תביא אותה למנחת המסוקים, קח אותה לאכסניה, קח אותה לחווה.
עכשיו אני פשוט ניצל לחלוטין על ידי הממשלה.
זו הייתה הפעם הראשונה שהזעקתי אמבולנס.
לא הייתי מוכן לזה.
ואז ידעתי שהצבא צופה בי.
ואז ידעתי טעות כפי שנקבעה על ידי סוכנות הביון הביטחונית שלנו באמצעות הוריי.
לא ממש.
אני כאן עובד עבור צ'רטר, אבל מסוגל לשגר רדאר וכל האותות האלקטרומגנטיים האחרים האלה.
זה טבעי.
הכלב מגיב באותה צורה שאני עושה.
אנחנו לא אומרים את זה לאנשים אלא אם כן אתה בחיל הנחתים למודעות מצבית.
עכשיו, סטינגריי ואופני עפר משתמשים באותו חלק גוף כי זה אלקטרומגנטי.
וב-1953, הדוד הגדול, הוא הביא הביתה כמה תמונות ומזל "טים אלקטרומגנטיים ו-1953 ושוב, אמא ואבא ב-1969 עובדים על פרויקט סאלוס, ששולט בכל מצב מולקולרי שמתרחש בתוך גוף האדם והחוצה.
עכשיו, אם תסתכלו על תאים עכשיו, הם יגידו לכם לוגיסטיקה ותנועה ובעצם כל דבר בינלאומי לפי מולקולה.
ואתה הולך, זה בלתי אפשרי.
זה בגלל שאתה לא יודע על ננו האינטרנט של הדברים, האינטרנט התעשייתי של הדברים, וכי רבות ממערכות ממשק המכונה האלה, הם היו בסביבה בשנת 1958.
אז למה שלא תספר לאנשים?
אני מתכוון, אדג'ווד ארסנל.
אנחנו בודקים את החיילים שלנו.
וייטנאם עם סבא שלי שוב.
יש לנו מזל "טים אלקטרומגנטיים בשנת 1953.
מה קורה פה?
נכון.
אז באתי לכאן למערב וירג'יניה והמוזרות עם האמבולנס ואז זה ממשיך.
יותר מוזרות, מכוניות נעלמות.
אז הולכים לחנויות הספרים ויש להם את השאלה הזו.
אה, אנחנו מתכננים עבור המחוז.
אני בעל בית, אז הלכתי קדימה והלכתי לבנות 60 דברים חדשים כאן בעיר של 200 אנשים.
הם היו לוקחים.
נראה מוזר.
הא.
אז זה גרם לי להתחיל לחקור שישה פינים והגעתי מהנדסת רשת ואבטחת סייבר זה אחד המקומות האהובים עלי כי אני עושה סביבות מתמטיות וזה היה חייב כי הייתי צריך לתת את הקצה האחורי של כוחות החלל לארבע כתובות נקודות שיצאו למכירה בפלורידה בשנה שעברה מזה.
באמת מעניין.
אבל גם אני הבנתי את זה.
אז בכל מקרה, כאשר אתה מהנדס רשת ואתה לומד עבור עמית רשת מוסמך סיסקו שלך עוד באותו היום היית צריך למעשה רשת משנה בינארית כי לא היו לנו מספיק כתובות IP.
אז כן, קראתי מתמטיקה בינומית.
זה חלק מהעבודה שלי בעבר.
בסדר.
אז כשזה מגיע לאבטחת סייבר, זה סוג הדברים בחלק הראשון הזה מלא לגמרי בדברים משעממים כאלה, כמו שכבות הצד והאינטרנט ודברים כאלה.
אז שוב, כשאתה צריך לרשת משנה ואתה צריך לבודד את הלקוחות שלך ואתה מחויב לאלפי אנשים מסוימים והם יתפסו אותך על היותך 300,000 דולר לדקה של הפסד, זו תקשורת צ'רטר באותה תקופה.
אז אתה צריך לדעת מה אתה עושה ואתה לא יכול לטעות.
400 אלף דולר בדקה.
כן, זה סוג של לחץ שאתה נמצא תחת עבודה כזו.
זכור, יש רק שני אנשים בכל המדינה שיכולים להתמודד עם הציוד הזה.
אז אתה לא יוצא לחופשות.
אתה בעצם צריך לעשות בייביסיטר לתוכנית.
כן.
אז אבטחת רשת, 60 רשת תקשורת אישית נמוכה.
והיא הולכת להשתמש במכונה למכונה כלומר אין בני אדם המעורבים ברכב אד הוק.
שימו לב, למשל, הנה חלוץ, הנה מזל"ט.
עכשיו, יש לי כמה בעיות.
קודם כל, אתה לא יכול להפריע למזל "ט הזה.
הצהרת הפנטגון 3000.09 טוענת לפני למעלה מ -11 שנים ותוכלו למצוא זאת ב- CSR.
לדוגמה, הפנטגון במאי השנה, 2022 אמר שאני חושב שהמפקדים שלנו בשטח צריכים להיות מסוגלים לקרוא את למידת המכונה.
ובכן, ברור שהמפקד, הבעל, ובמיוחד המפקד, לא השתתף בסימפוזיון הבינה המלאכותית ב -10 בספטמבר 2020.
אם המפקד היה עושה זאת, הוא היה יודע שזו לא מערכת עצבים דיגיטלית מקצה לקצה מבלי שבני אדם מעורבים בפרויקט סלוס.
מה למדנו בחזרה למסירת מוצרים?
תן להם את הקוד.
פלטפורמת Salus משמשת עבור NORTHCOM עם שדרוגים לספקים.
מחליף המשחק הוא שמוצרי האב-טיפוס העצביים החדשים נמצאים בפיתוח ולכו לכאן.
אז מה?
אב טיפוס עצבי חדש Synchro בתור התחלה, הבינה המלאכותית של G Joint.
מה זה Fuzing הוא ארגון מטושטש שמתמקד בהוצאת מוצרים מהדלת לאנשים שמשתמשים בהם בפועל.
אחר כך הם התווכחו אם זה הולך להיות שירותי רשת הכלאה של אמזון או דיגיטציה, ומיקרוסופט ואמזון היו כמו, או תנו לי לקבל חוזה ממשלתי.
בסדר.
ואז זה נהיה מוזר יותר בשבילי.
וכשאני מקשיב, הם אמרו שירותי תיוג נתונים.
ואני כאילו, זה איסוף נתונים מסיבי של מסד נתונים.
ואני חושב על מה שלקוחות הספקים ואני כתבנו, זה משרד ההגנה.
אז בשביל זה אתה יכול ללכת לכאן להתחלה וזה אומר כך הצוות של ג'ייק אני מתכוון הוועדה המשותפת לבינה מלאכותית, התפקיד שלהם הוא להפוך את AI.
אמיתי וכולם יכולים וצריכים ליישם בינה מלאכותית בכל מה שהם עושים.
לקוחות ברחבי משרד ההגנה.
מה הלקוחות שלך?
צפה בזה.
אז כלים מנוגדים נמצאים תחת מטריית Tradewinds והפרויקט Maven ואני מצטטים צינורות חמים באמצעות חיישנים חכמים, קבוצת עבודה אלחוטית של Biosensors 82.1 5.5 רשתות חיישנים אלחוטיות קבוצת עבודה מיוחדת לסטנדרטים הבינלאומיים של אלקטרוניקה והנדסה סליחה, אלקטרוניקה והנדסת חשמל.
ופרויקט מייבן משתמש ב- Pathfinder ואני כדי לראות אותך מסתובב וחושב בתוך הבית שלך בזמן אמת.
ובואו נצטט את פרויקט MQ תשע קשור לקרקע.
זו הוראת משרד ההגנה 3000.09, שטענה שוב, זו הסיבה שהמפקד היה עצבני כי הוא כאילו, אנחנו לא יכולים לשמוע את המכונות האלה, אנחנו לא יכולים לפענח אותן מטבען ואנחנו לא יכולים להעביר אות.
ואני מצטט כאן בשער, אנחנו צריכים לקבל את המערכת של IBM של חיל האוויר מלוכדת יותר עם כל השאר.
אנחנו ניצור מערכת עצבים דיגיטלית מקצה לקצה.
אנחנו צריכים לעשות שוב במשרד ההגנה איך לחבר את כל הפלטפורמות של IBM.
במה הם שולטים?
פלטפורמות לסביות, כלי רכב אוטונומיים.
אתה מתכוון מזל "טים אוטונומיים, טנקים, סטרייקרים רגילים, כל מיני דברים.
מטוסים, לבדוק.
מה לגבי כל דבר אחר?
-בהחלט.
האינטרנט התעשייתי של הדברים במיליארדים האלה שיש להם כלי רכב בנהיגה עצמית והכל אוויר של בעלות הברית.
אבל חשבת שזה רק עבור החלק החכם צריך לבדוק את הדרך החדשה להנדסת RF להציל את היום שנקרא הדרך הירוקה.
זה לא סיבים מיוחדים חדשים לאורך הכביש המהיר.
כשנשאל האם אתה יכול פשוט להשתמש במעט אור להזיז את הצד ההררי שמציב מלכים וגישה מיוחדת המכון הלאומי למדע וטכנולוגיה של קרטיס לממשלה זה משלם לאנשים זה לא בדיחה פרויקטים שחורים זכור שאני לא באמת משלם 45 אלף על מושב אסלה שלם.
לא, הם לא.
אבל אתה יודע מה?
הם עושים את האירוסים המגעילים.
כדי שלאנשים תהיה ערימה כזו, הם צריכים לחבר חמישה קודים כדי להסתיר לאן הולך כל הכסף והקצאת המשאבים והלוגיסטיקה והמשלוח, ואז הקצאה מחדש של אנשי פרויקטים בעלי גישה מיוחדת, ואז הקצאה מחדש של מי שאחראי לשמור עליהם, לעקוב אחריהם, לאתר אותם, או את משרד ההגנה לרשימה לשינוי פרויקטים בגישה מיוחדת.
זה יוצא משליטה והכל קוד פתוח ואתה יכול לקרוא עליו ולחפש אותו בגוגל.
אז זו הבעיה שלנו כאן.
אז אתה רוצה להסביר לי, מה הם חיישנים ביולוגיים אלה ועל מה אתה מדבר?
מזל "ט MQ תשע Reaper.
זה קשור לדנ "א שלי.
מה קורה פה?
ודרך אגב, מי הם הלקוחות שלך?
-למעשה.
אבטחת סייבר.
כן.
בינה מלאכותית סימפוזיון ראשון.
הם אמרו להם שכל בני האדם אינם מהדרך, אז אני צריך לנסח את זה שאחד למערכת העצבים הדיגיטלית מקצה לקצה עבור הפלטפורמות האלה המחוברות לבני האדם מחוץ לתהליך ולהיגיון, לאפשר למנהל הנוכחי ישירות להשתמש בתאי אשראי במדעי הנתונים ו.
מאז שהייתי ילד.
ראיונות ממשק מכונה.
מאגרי מידע קוונטיים.
מתאם מנהל.
עכשיו למה שהם יעשו את זה?
אז רשת האיזור האישית החדשה של 60 הולכת להשתמש בגופך כדי לנתב את הנתונים.
ולפני שאתה חושב, הו לא, הם היו אומרים לנו שזה נעשה בשנת 2005.
זה מה שרשת החיישנים האלחוטיים.
החיישנים הביולוגיים הם בעצם קבועים וחיים מאז 2005 ומאז 2005 עם זיגבי ובלוטות', וזה מה שהתלוננתי עליו קודם כששלחתי אותו, הייתי רק ילד.
מדוע זיגבי ו- Bluetooth וחיישנים ביולוגיים אלה נראים בדיוק כך?
כי ככה זה עובד.
התקנים הבינלאומיים להנדסת אלקטרוניקה וחשמל משתמשים ברשת אזור גוף רחבה וב- 82.1 5.6 תקנים אלקטרוניים לקבוצת עבודה אלחוטית Wide Body Area Network 82.1 5.6.
ואלה ארבעת המעגלים של הכתיבה הטכנית שלהם של מה שהם מסוגלים לעשות דרך הגוף שלך.
וכמו תמיד, אתה יודע, לא צריכים להיות לנו יותר משותקים והכל.
הם יכולים לגרום לידיים שלך לזוז.
הם עוקבים אחר צפיפות רקמת השריר שלך.
הם יכולים לגרום לך לדבר.
הם יכולים.
והם עושים עכשיו.
הם עוקבים אחר כל הדברים האלה באופן אלחוטי.
איך זה אפשרי אם הגוף שלך צריך לביש או שהם משתמשים בנתב שלך או שהם משתמשים במתג שלך כמו ב- או שהם משתמשים בנתב שלך או שהם משתמשים במשהו אחר?
רציתי לדעת, אז הבנתי את זה.
עם אבטחת הסייבר החדשה כאן עם הסטרייקר והיא צריכה להיות מכונה למכונה, בדיוק כמו בסימפוזיון ב- DIA de אמר.
הבעיה היא שאוטונומיה היא N9 ריק הקשור ל- DNA שלך וכי ה- DNA מייצר חלק גוף אלקטרומגנטי.
ואף אחד לא יודע על זה.
הם קוראים לזה ההילה, הם קוראים לזה כל מיני דברים.
אה, זה עב "מים.
אנחנו לא יודעים.
כן, אנחנו עושים.
סקאנקוורקס, ריית'און.
אני רק הראיתי לך את התמונה.
אנשי המזל "ט יכולים לעבוד במשך 40 שנים פלוס, לקבל תשלום באמת, באמת.
ובכן.
אנחנו שומרים אותך בחושך.
אבטחת סייבר, צבא, אתה יודע, ביטחון לאומי.
אה, זה עב "מים בואש, ריית'און, לוקהיד.
כולם יודעים את זה.
הם ספקים.
אז מה כל הדברים האלה על רשומות נפשיות?
מדענים.
הם טבועים ברקמות אנושיות.
אז היה ספר שפעם קראתי את התלמידים שלי כשלימדתי על זה בילדותי.
הנה זה בשנת 1996.
הספר הזה נכתב.
זה נקרא פסיכולוגיה אינטגרלית.
ובתוכך תמצאו את מה שאמרתי כרגע על טלפתיה, אמפתיה, הכרה מוקדמת, הכל.
זה מוקצה לאזורים מסוימים במוח.
אז האם רשתות החיישנים האלה יורדות לקנה המידה הננו?
ואז הם שמו את זה על תוכנה קניינית כשהם צריכים לכתוב עבור זיגבי ו- Bluetooth עבור אותם חיישנים ביולוגיים קבועים לכל החיים, ואתה יודע, 2.1, 5.4, הם מודבקים לצמיתות לגוף שלך איפה.
מסנכרן תדר הרדיו.
יש שניים מהם.
הם הולכים למשוך את כל האנרגיה האלקטרומגנטית, כולל העצמה של מינרלים, מזרם הדם הביוכימי שלך ולהמיר אותם כי השדה האלקטרומגנטי שלך כאן שחשבת שהוא חסר ערך לא היה קיים, וכולם צחקו עליך.
זה למעשה מתמר כל דבר אלקטרומגנטית.
עכשיו אנחנו משתמשים רדיו סינתטי.
זהו רדיו מוגדר תוכנה.
טלפתיה סינתטית, רק כדי להרגיז את העור שלך.
מעט מועבר אלקטרומגנטית פנימה והחוצה, תוך שימוש בחלקי הגוף שלך.
אז איך אתה חושב שהם למעלה?
נתוני מחשב?
באותה הדרך.
החיישניים הביולוגיים הם מגנטים מילוליים.
הם קבועים ומותאמים עם מתח.
כיצד לקבוצת עבודה אלחוטית ADA 2.15.5.
וזו הרשת האיזרית האישית שלך.
אלה גם הרשת האישית שלך.
הזמן שלי, כפי שאתם יכולים לראות כאן, ל-6 G Maupin אולי יש או לא רשת אזור גוף למטרות ניתוב אבטחה.
הם מנתבים את הנתונים שלהם דרך הרקמה שלך ואני מצטט חילופי מידע דיגיטלי תוך שימוש במוליכות החשמלית של גוף האדם כרשת אזור גוף של רשת נתונים.
אז למה אנחנו לא צריכים שבב מוח?
כי אתה אלחוטי כבר 6000 שנה.
רפואה סינית, המרידיאנים, הצ'אקרות, אלה נקודות הניוד על הגוף שלך, טלמטריה אלקטרומגנטית אלקטרומגנטית.
אז החיישים הביולוגיים הקבועים הופצו לכולם כאן ב-82.1, 5.4, והם היו צריכים להיות קבועים עבור זיגבי ובלוטות', וזה מה שמספק אותם.
ואז מד קבוצת העבודה האלחוטית 2.1, 5.5 דואג לכל סוגי הרשתות השונות, ואז אוסף חיישנים מסוימים מגופים מסוימים בלבד, נתיב פתוח הקצר ביותר, פרוטוקולי ניתוב ראשונים או סיבות מונעות אבטחה.
אבל הם גם, כאשר הם יוצרים אותם עם זיגבי ו- Bluetooth, הם צריכים לבחור סוג רקמת שריר.
מאז 2008, הם צריכים לבחור חום כדי שלא תריח מוות.
וכך הם עבדו על זה עד 2011, בשנת 2013.
ועכשיו יש להם בערך 13 פרוטוקולי ניתוב שונים, אבל רק כשלושה מהם בנויים כדי להגן עליך מפני המידע שאתה נושא על ידי ניתוב נתונים דרך הגוף שלך, אשר מושך מינרלים מתאי הדם האדומים שלך לעשות זאת.
עכשיו, זו הודעה מאוד מינורית ברמה אפס עד שיותר מדי חברות מושכות את הנתונים הסטטיסטיים האלה באופן מתמטי בו זמנית.
והנה איך זה נראה.
אז ממש כאן בדוגמה הקטנה שלנו, אולי תרצו גם לציין ששני אלה הם של שישה לכל אחד מהם חמישה צמתים בולטים מהם, תויגו ממש כאן ואחד, שניים, שלושה, ארבעה, חמישה.
אז עבור כל נקודה קטנה, יש לך עוד חמש והם כולם נגישים אלקטרומגנטית דרך הענן מסחרית עם זיגבי ו Bluetooth, אשר שוב הוא למעשה, אתה יודע, 2.1, 5.4, כי אם הם לא היו, הם לא היו יכולים למכור זיגבי ו Bluetooth בקיר.
הם לא יכלו להשתמש באלכסה ככה.
כל הדברים השונים האלה מתקשרים עם רשתות החיישנים האלה, וכולם מונעים על ידי מאגרי מידע של בינה מלאכותית וכולם משולבים זה בזה.
אז אם אתה אלחוטי ואתה באותה קבוצת עבודה אלחוטית כמו הטלפון שלך, שהוא למעשה, אתה יודע, 2.1.
אז ברשת אזורית אישית רחבה, הם מנתבים את הנתונים שלהם דרככם.
מאז 2005 ואני יכול לכתוב אפליקציה בשביל זה ואז אני יכול לשחק איתך ככה כי אלה כאן נגישים מאז 2005.
אתה חושב שלאנשים לא היה מספיק זמן לקנות טלפתיה סינתטית, ציוד לביש?
הכל כתוב.
ואם לא ידעתם איך כתיבת אפליקציה אינה קשה וה- GitHub מעצב אותה עם משהו שנקרא שפת שאילתה מובנית, היי, מה יבקש מכם לצאת לקצה האחורי של מיקרוסופט, אפאצ'י וורדפרס ולשאול את כולכם, היי, זה Hadoop של סגנון.
אז האנשים האלה בשנות התשעים לפני שזה התגלגל בשנת 2005, ועל ידי האנשים האלה אני מתכוון לסנאי הסודי של ההורים שלי, אכיפת החוק הסודית כל הדברים האלה שוב למי שוב כוח החלל מאז 1969 מאותת מודיעין וכו '.
אוקיי אז יש להם משהו שנקרא ממשק מוח מוח, טלפתיה סינתטית וזה מונע תדר עמית לעמית.
כן.
והם חבשו קסדה ליד השולחן שלהם והם יכולים לשוט ישר דרך רקמות אנושיות.
שוב, הדברים האלה מנוטרים בזמן אמת.
תגיד לנו אם זה לא היה מספיק גרוע.
יש להם גם אותך לפי כל מאגרי האיסוף שאתה רואה המפורטים כאן.
אז הטלוויזיה, כל החושים, הדברים, המכ "ם, הדופלר ואז ארגזי העפר עפים מעל ראשך והם מתקשרים עם תוכנת הסטינגריי, שנכתבה עבור מחלקות שריף בודדות, תלוי באיזה סוג מאגרי מידע הם רוצים להירשם.
אז מה שאתה מסיים איתו, זה כאן שלוש גופות שהולכות לאורך הכביש.
יש שתי גופות בבית.
גופים אלה מנוצלים כעת על ידי אותו נהג מכיוון שלגופם יש במקרה את האבטחה הטובה ביותר במכונה.
מכונה משתמשת רק בקריטריונים אלה והם מופיעים ברשימה אם ברצונך לקרוא את המכונה, ללמוד לצפות בהזמנה.
ואז המפתח להפרדה של כמה פעמים הם פגעו בצומת, כמה זמן הם מחכים .06 עיכוב שני.
וזה אותו דבר באבטחת סייבר לכל דבר.
שלום.
להתראות.
לסירוגין.
חכי, תישארי.
ואם אתה יודע משהו על פריצת נתונים עם מנות אמיתיות ולא רק על חומרי הענן הארגוניים המוגדרים בתוכנה, כלומר ובעיקר שימוש בתוכנה, אני מתכוון כמו צד החומרה, הם מפרקים את כל החבילה לשכבת כתובת ה- Mac הפיזית של הגוף שלך.
זו הבעיה שאנחנו נמצאים בה.
זו הסיבה שאנחנו למטה עד חוט כאן.
הם מחוברים למח העצם שלהם.
והדרך שבה סיסקו מקאן מפעילה את כל מה שמסביבם ברשת החכמה היא כשאתה הולך, כשאתה רוקד, וכשאתה זז.
וזה עוד חלק שאתה יכול לקרוא עליו בשמונה, 2.1, 5.5 ורשתות שטח גוף רחבות 802.15.6.
אז שוב, הבעיה שאנו נתקלים בה היא שכאשר יש לך שלוש גופות שהולכות בכביש, שני אלה יורים עכשיו טונות של אותות שאמרו לך שכל צומת הוא עוד חמישה.
עכשיו, כל החיישנים האלה משתגעים.
האדם הזה כאן, המכונה בוחר את האדם הזה כאן, את ה- DNA, את ה- DNA שלך, את הגוף שלך.
זה מה שיוצר את האות המאובטח שהמזל"ט משתמש בו הוא הפצת ה- DNA שלך.
וכך בדיוק זה עובד.
אז כדי למנוע מהמל"ט הזה לירות כל דבר, אתה צריך לעצור את ה- DNA שלך מלהתפשט.
למה שהם יעשו את זה?
אז בפעם האחרונה.
אם אתה חסר מזל מספיק ומישהו מקבל מכה עם נשק ביולוגי.
זוהי התמרה חשמלית על קבוצת העבודה האלחוטית הפתוחה של רשתות אזור גוף רחבות.
אז זה לא משנה במה אתה מאמין.
וזה מעולם לא קרה.
הם עשו את כל זה ממש כאן.
שניכם הייתם מדיום.
ואז כשהם העבירו בני אדם והם מבצעים בדיקות ממשיות, שהן הנדסת רקמות אלחוטיות ושליטה פיזואלקטרית כוללת אלחוטית, הפחתה עצבית לאפנון התנהגותי.
יש לנו נזק מוחי.
אתה מתכוון לאזורים ננומטריים עדינים מאוד במוח שלך כדי לשמור על ההתנהגות שלך תחת שליטה.
ואז אנו שולחים אותך לאנשים ואומרים לך שטיפול קוגניטיבי התנהגותי יעזור לך בקוגר זקוק לתכנות בינה מלאכותית.
אנחנו יודעים שאם אתה אומר את זה שוב ושוב, אתה הולך לעשות את זה.
אז למה שהם לא יתקנו את הסביבה האפיגנטית שלך?
כי הם לא מעוניינים בזה.
או שהם היו מספרים לאנשים על הדברים האלה מזמן.
הם למדו תחבורה והם היו בודקים אנשים על כך על מדע היכולות שלהם לביואינפורמטיקה וגנומיקה.
ברגע שהגוף שלך כבר לא יכול היה להעביר את האותות האלקטרומגנטיים האלה, זה לא טבעי, זה יותר מדי כוח בזרם הדם, בעצמות ובמערכת כלי הדם שלך.
בסופו של דבר זה מחליש את הוורידים, העורקים, העור, ואז אתה בצרות.
אז אתה מעמיד פנים שאתה הולך לאיבוד ביער?
האם אתה הולך למחתרת?
אני צוחק.
אז זה מה שהם עשו.
אף אחד לא אמר את האמת.
סטינגריי ואכיפת החוק היו כולם עטופים בשנת 1972.
אז השתמשו בי על ידי מפקד המשטרה עם המוח שלי או, סלחו לי, ממשק גוף המכונה שלי באותה תקופה, כי הם עדיין היו צריכים שולחן לימוד עם ננו ליפיד או הידרוג'ל כדי שיוכלו לעבור ולהראות את זה על צג.
זה מה שכל השומרים האלה הם.
אז עכשיו כולם שקטים מאז 2005 וזמינים מסחרית.
ושוב, התקן החדש לאבטחת סייבר הוא רשת אזור גוף רחבה אשר עשויה להיות מעורבת או לא עשויה להיות מעורבת ברשת אזורית אישית אשר עשויה או לא עשויה לערב את ה- iPad שלך ואת כל השאר.
אבטחת הסייבר ממש כאן, פברואר 2022, תפתח שש פעמים זיהוי דיגיטלי.
ניתוב והרעיונות הדיגיטליים העשויים מהטלפון שלך.
זה נכון.
תדירות ומגורים של מה שלך?
ה- DNA שלך יצר אלקטרומגנטית נגישה אלחוטית מאז 2005 חלק גוף מסחרי.
הם אף פעם לא יידעו אותך על כך שהרופא שלך לא יודה בזה.
אתה תלמד.
אנחנו נדבר על זה.
ואם תנסה.
אבל לעשות ממך צחוק.
למה?
אתה לא רוצה שליטה מוחלטת ובני אדם ויש להם אותם על שלטים כדי לגרום להם לעשות מה שאתה רוצה?
אין רצון חופשי, אין יכולת לחשוב.
אמרתי לך.
הפחתה עצבית עם עדין.
מה שוב?
שינוי התנהגות.
עוד פעם אחת.
סימנים חיוניים, נשימה.
-קל.
ניטור ACG לפקח על מכשיר שמיעה לגלוקוז.
מהם השימושים הלא רפואיים של מה שאתה מכניס לעצם שלך?
כי כשהם יעשו זאת, תאי הדם האדומים שלך צריכים לפעול לניתוב והם ימשכו מגנטית את אלה סליחה, המינרלים האלה קשים על הכתף שלי, היישר מזרם הדם שלך.
ובכן, נתוני הזרמת וידאו, ספורט העברת קבצים, תלת מימד, וידאו, דברים שנשכחו, צג.
ואז עוד פעם אחת אתה תהיה רשאי לעשות שלושה דברים יישומי בידור, יחסי ציבור ומשחקים ורשתות חברתיות.
מתחילים לראות כיצד המטא-וורס מפעיל את האינטרנט של הדברים, האינטרנט של הגופים, האינטרנט הקיברנטי של הדברים.
הכל קשור יחד בתוך המוח שלך שם, כאן.
אז כשניסיתי לספר לאנשים איך אני מפרויקטים של דם ואתה צריך להבין את החלק הזה בגוף ואם אתה לא מתחיל לעבוד עם זה, אתה מתחיל להבין את זה.
זוהי לוחמת מזל "ט אתה הולך לחכות לך אתה לא אף אחד.
אז מה שאתה צריך לעשות זה להבין שהדבר היחיד שיש לך כרגע הוא הפיזיולוגיה קודם, כלומר להודות שזה חלק הגוף.
הם פגעו בו לשעבוד אנושי מוחלט ויש להם את זה.
זה מדהים שהכל נעשה במשטרה, במחלקות השריף.
כמו שאמרתי, הם סיימו בשנת 1972, להיות מסוגלים לדבר אחד עם השני עם טלפתיה סינתטית וחבורה של ילדים קטנים.
ואז כשהיינו בני נוער, הנה הגיע כל השאר עם 2013 היה כאשר הם למעשה גלגלו ממשק שבב מוח.
מבחינה מקצועית, אנשים עדיין לא יודעים את זה.
הם עדיין חושבים שאתה צריך שבב אמיתי במוח שלך.
אתה לא.
אתה פשוט הולך לקנות אנטנת ננו עם התדר הנכון עבור רשת אזור הגוף הרחב.
זה כמו מאה דולר ואז אתה קונה טלפתיה סינתטית של 200 דולר המייצרת לביש שפשוט נכנס לתוך עצבי הגולגולת שלך בעדינות ומאפשר לך לשמוע את כל האותות סביבך שמקרינים ברשתות האלה.
רשתות אלה מחוברות לכל דבר באינטרנט של הדברים, האינטרנט התעשייתי של הדברים, סייבר ננו אינטרנט של גופים, ולועגים לכם גופי אינטרנט אליהם.
כאילו, כאילו אתה לא יודע את הספציפיות, אז אתה צריך כי אז הם אמרו, אה, אבל זה רק בבתי חולים.
ואני כאילו, לא, לא, לא, לא, לא, לא, לא, לא, לא, לא.
זה פשוט טיפשי, אני מתכוון, אני מתכוון, זה תכנון מהנדס.
למה שתשאיר את זה רק בבית החולים?
אני מתכוון, זה אפילו לא יתפקד ככה.
זה אלחוטי לחלוטין, לווין, כולל.
אז במזל"ט הזה בוחר את ה- DNA שלך כי ה- MQ תשע הזה נקשר אליך.
זכור שהרגע ציינתי את זה ואני הולך להגיד MQ תשע.
עשר בספטמבר 2020.
בינה מלאכותית פנטגון MQ תשע קשור לקרקע פרויקט Maven Project Pathfinder עם זיהוי אובייקטים.
זה נכון.
באזור גוף קוגניטיבי, הרשתות הופכות להיות כל כך מבולבלות מכיוון שהן משתמשות במשהו שנקרא רשת יריבה והן תוקפות אותך.
כי הם צופים.
אתה חושב עם ההערות האלה קוגניטיבית לצפייה במכ"ם קוגניטיבי אתה חושב בזמן אמת.
וזה מופיע בתלבושת קטנטנה והם לוחצים על כפתור.
הם קיבלו התקף לב ושבץ מוחי או כל דבר שהם רוצים, כל מולקולה, כל מצב שאנחנו מתמודדים איתו, הכל זמין להם מאז 2005.
אה, מינימום.
ההורים שלי עברו את ההליך הזה, אז זה בשנת 1969.
כל מולקולה על פני כדור הארץ, בכל מקום.
אז איך הגענו לכאן?
איך כל זה הגיע למקום?
בלי אחריות נפשית, בלי שקר, כלום.
אנחנו פשוט נותנים להם להתחמק מזה קודם.
הם התחשמלו בעדינות.
הרבה אנשים קיבלו פיברומיאלגיה, אבל אף אחד לא ידע.
אמרתי, גידול הוא שיש לך גידול, אבל אנחנו לא יכולים למצוא אותו פיזית.
זה רק המוח שלך מתנהג כמו אז התקף פסאודו.
אז, אלוהים, אנחנו לא יודעים למה יש לך כל כך הרבה התקפים אז.
זאבת, מחלת לו גריג, אוטואימונית 80% ממערכת החיסון שלך נמצאת באותו חלק גוף בלתי נראה ב 40 עד 60% מהמערכת האנדוקרינית שלך.
אז בגלל זה כל ההורמונים לעולם לא יכולים להשתלט.
אתה ממשיך לדפוק עם התמרה החשמלית של מבנה התא הבסיסי של האיבר הגדול ביותר שלך.
קדימה, אנשים.
ואז הם לא.
מחלות.
אה, אני לא יודע מה זה.
הם עושים.
ארגון הבריאות העולמי הודה כי סרטן הוא לא הסיפור שלי לספר, ולכן אני משאיר אותו פתוח.
אז הרבה אנשים כבר הבינו את זה עם סרטן.
הם כאילו, רגע, אני חולה שעכשיו אתה רוצה שאקח כימותרפיה?
כמו מה?
וכן, אז לא מר.
אנדו, אבל עכשיו אנחנו כל הדרך לכאן לתוך תסמונת מוות מבוגר פתאומי.
אלוהים, אנחנו לא יודעים למה.
וכאשר הם מסתובבים יותר מדי ויש להם חמצן מועבר בתאי הדם האדומים, יותר מדי קורה יותר מדי מכ"ם משירותי הספנות של אמזון.
יש יותר מדי התייחסות מחברות רגילות רק לאבטחה.
אולי זו רק חברה רגילה שמחפרת גיאולוגיה או חלק עליון של סט סלעים או מה שלא יהיה עכשיו שהיא מושכת מהגוף שלך כדי לסרוק את האזור.
שוב, זה רק חלק מקבוצת עבודה של חיישנים אלחוטיים כאן של ה- ATO, 2.1, 5.5 ונקודה ארבע.
אבל עכשיו זה משתמש בגוף שלך כי אתה ב, אתה יודע, 2.1, 5.6.
ולמטרות שלנו, בשביל זה, במקום הסטרייקר, זה לוויין.
היא צריכה את הגוף שלך בשמונה או 2.1, 5.6.
אלה חיישנים לכל החיים קבועים מאז 2005 זמינים מסחרית.
ומשרד ההגנה מוכר דרך מסד הנתונים גישה אליך באמצעות אותו מפקד אוכלוסין ודופלר וחום ואור ואיפה אתה גר ועם מי אתה מדבר.
ולכן כל הסיבה שהובילה אותי לכאן הייתה כשהבנתי שהמחוז שלי, מי שזה לא יהיה שאני גר בקרבתו, העיירה הקטנה שלי בת 200, עוברת דרך מחזור הדם שלי.
זה עדיין פתוח וזה הפחיד אותי.
עקבתי אחר הקישור ועשיתי את הקריאה כל כך בפריסה ארצית ושוב, זה 2022 פברואר לדיגיטל.
קפצתי על גיאופנסינג ותפסתי אנשים כדי שלא יוכלו לעזוב את הגיאופנס שלהם.
אבל אף אחד לא אמר לך שאתה אלחוטי כי הם לא רוצים לתת לך את השלט רחוק לגוף שלך.
אז מה אתה הולך לעשות בקשר לזה כשהרדאר יגיע אליך והיא תהיה מוכנה עם הדנ "א שלה לסיים אותך?
כי זו הצהרת הנשק הקטלנית האוטונומית שהמשכתי לקרוא מתוך ספר הלימוד של המכללה.
כן.
אז אתה לא יכול לשמוע את זה, נכון?
הגוף שלך לא ישמע את זה נכנס, בין אם זה מזל"ט או צינור טרנס.
ובכל זאת זה אור בערוץ שלי, אודיסיאה.
הוא מלא בניצולי לוחמה אלקטרומגנטית, אנשים כמוני שהחומר הזה נבדק עליהם ואז יושם בסולם הממשל התעשייתי עבור סוכנות הביון הביטחונית, NRO, או מי שלא יהיה.
אנחנו חייבים להבין עכשיו הוא שאתה אתה מחוץ לזמן כי הם הולכים למלחמה.
והם עושים את זה מאז 2005.
ושוב, המשפחה שלי הייתה בשנת 1969.
אז כאן בערוץ שלי, אני מלמד תרגול ביופילם, אני מלמד התקפה והגנה.
הגנה זה נהדר כי אז אתה פותח את עצמך בתוך השדה שלך ואתה לומד איך להקשיב ולנשום בפועל.
אבל תרגול ביופילם פוגעני הגיע בשבוע שעבר, ולפחות הצעתי לך להתבונן בו לפני שאתה מנסה אותו ולפני שאתה עושה משהו אתה מכיר את הגוף שלך שוב ולתקן את כל הדברים שלימדו אותך לא נכון כדי שיוכלו לגשת אליך בשלט הרחוק, לקחת את המערכת החיסונית שלך, כי מה שהולך לקרות הוא מטעני הפלזמה.
ואם תראו את זה 2030 מדבר על זה, מטעני הפלזמה האלה.
כן, זה נכון.
חלק גוף אלקטרומגנטי, אתה הולך להרגיש את זה בכל מקרה.
אבל אם יש לך ידע מבעוד מועד, אתה לא תפחד ותהיה מוכן יותר להתבונן בסביבה שלך מבחינה טופולוגית אפיגנטית ולהבין באמת את האנשים ששותפים לכל הדברים האלה שהם באמת רעים.
הם יגידו לך שהביופילמים שלך מתחילים אמיתיים או שהם לא ידברו על זה.
ואז אם הם מעורבים בכשני שלישים, המטרות של המדינה הזו מעורבות.
הם פשוט יעמידו פנים שזה לא משנה וזה, אה, זה לא יכול להשפיע עלי.
אני מאמין שזה מרכז המהפכה.
הם מנסים לפגוע במדינה שלנו כי בני הנוער שלנו מסוכנים את החומר הזה והם יודעים כמה קל לרכוש את ה-400 דולר האלה ולקיים טלפתיה ולהשפיע על אנשים בהוליווד.
הם עושים את זה כבר הרבה זמן.
ובכן, עכשיו הם לוקחים את זה צעד קדימה עם מגמות הנדסת רקמות, הגדלה.
ואמרתי לאנשים, הם הולכים להפוך את החלק התחתון של הזרוע שלך לדגים.
אבל אז הם כמו, אה, אנחנו לא ביחד.
אז עכשיו זה כאן.
יש שם רופאים המציעים לשנות את ה- DNA של אנשים ולשנות אותם למצבי בעלי חיים וכו '.
כן, אנחנו יודעים שזה מה שכל יום זה משחק תפקיד בו.
אוקיי, אז צעד ראשון, אתה חייב להיות כנה לגבי הפיזיולוגיה שלך.
יש לך חלק גוף בלתי נראה וכולם יודעים חוץ ממך.
זאת בעיה.
למה?
כי הגוף שלך הוא מה שחשוב.
כל הגוף באופן מיידי.
עכשיו תקרין את התחום הזה.
ספורט קיטור.
זה היה שלם.
בואו נסתכל על ההטיה שנראית למעשה כאילו מדובר באנרגיה אלקטרומגנטית, לא?
אתה שומע את המזל "טים מגיעים.
אתה הולך להרגיש את זה.
הגוף שלך עושה זאת באופן טבעי.
אלגור נראה לציפורים.
כל הדברים האלה מציינים קווי ליי.
הצבא משתמש בהם זמן רב.
למה לא ידעת?
למה אסור לך לדעת?
שלב ראשון זה חלק הגוף שלך.
שלב שני להסתדר עם אלוהים.
תפילה לאנשים שהם כמו אחד.
ישו.
אוקיי, טוב, מה שאתה רוצה.
פיזיולוגיה.
ראשון.
זה חלק גוף ומסתכם עם אלוהים.
תפילה לאנשים לייצג את כל צורות האהבה.
ואז לתרגל דתות, מה שלא יהיה.
אוקיי, הודעה מופרדת.
שכל מה שאתה מאמין בו הוא החובה שאוהבת אותך.
לדעת שיש שם משהו גדול יותר מאשר את עצמך.
זה פרטי.
זה אישי.
הנשמה שלך, ישות ריבונית בעור שלך.
סופר.
בסדר.
אז לכל אחד שיהיו מגנטים עם כיוונון מתח ואז העביר את זה לרשויות אכיפת החוק ומעקב סודי וללא רופאים, שום דבר.
במשך כמה שנים?
ואז פתאום, אחרי שהפרויקט אומר, תקשיב, אני הולך, אלוהים אדירים, אנחנו בכל כך הרבה צרות.
חתולים, כלבים ודגי זהב.
ואז נהייתי ממש פטפטן השנה באפריל.
ואמרתי, הכלבה הבועה, הנה הוורידים והעורקים שלך.
הם בסדר גמור.
בסדר גמור עכשיו.
הם לא משקיעים הרבה מאמץ, כלומר.
אבל כל כך הרבה מאמץ.
זה הוא.
צפו בזהירות ואז צפו כיצד נראית הביוספרה כשהיא מצפה במלואה.
מעוות.
נחרץ.
אתה לא לוחץ על ההדק.
יהיה לך מזל אם תוכל אפילו להגיע לדלת שלי.
ודרך אגב, הכרה מוקדמת, שוב, הספר שהראיתי לכם, עכבישים אוכלים איתו.
אז למה אתה עדיין מעמיד פנים שאתה לא בסוכנות הביון הביטחונית שלהם?
מאגרי מידע של הפנטגון עם כל חלום שיש לך ושההכרה המוקדמת שלך מתבוננת גם בגלל ברקמה שלך.
בגלל זה עכבישים אוכלים עם זה.
אותו דבר עם אלגור.
זה הכל טבעי וכולם תמיד כמו, הו, אני אוהב להיות בטבע.
למה כל החוטים והדברים האלה?
ודי מהר הם הולכים להיעלם.
ורוב האנשים לא ידעו שיש לנו את כל הפלזמה האטומית הזו וכל השאר.
היה לנו את זה בשנות ה-1800 והם לקחו את זה ל-150 שנה כדי שיוכלו למכור לך בחזרה את המערכת החיסונית שלך ולכלוא אותך.
עכשיו הם יודעים שאין לנו את הדלק הביולוגי שלך ואת הלוחמה האלקטרומגנטית הקרובה.
אתה לא תשרוד.
זה כל כך פשוט.
אז הסיכויים שלך עכשיו ואין לך הרבה זמן.
1953.
מה אתה חושב שיש להם עכשיו?
אתה.
ואז.